hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel uh where if you're new here
and you don't know me i just want to
apologize for the lighting
i am currently locked in a hotel room
for two weeks and it is not
ideal that means the only light i have
is the one from my laptop right now
sorry about that so today we're talking
about something that
i get asked about pretty frequently
we're going to talk about hot tub
streamers
um titty streamers i suppose some recent
news regarding
twitch removing ads from some of these
streamers reinstating them
and then issuing a statement but for
context because it's going to be part of
what i'm talking about the question that
i get asked most frequently and feel
like i've been asked for
years at this point is if i feel like as
a woman who streams and does not show
any of my body
um if women who do hot tub streams are
hurting me in some way it's
a very specific question that i get
quite frequently things along the lines
of
don't you feel like these are hurting
other female content creators they're
taking
views away from legit content creators
they are giving female gamers a bad
image
etc so i guess just for context again
for anyone who might watch this who has
no idea who i am
this is generally what my streams look
like pretty much always wearing a shirt
or a hoodie uh something
along that description it's a lot of
gray apparently we're a lot of gray
so we'll go over the news before i dive
into um any of you know the answering of
the question that i've been getting
asked here let me make myself smaller
okay so this is an article from news.com
it says alarming hot tub streamer
amaranth i'm hoping that i'm pronouncing
her username correctly
reacts after twitch advertising revenue
suddenly cut off goes on to say a woman
who rakes in cash from controversial hot
tub streams on twitch has reacted after
her ad revenue
was suddenly cut off yeah she is
currently live though not in the video
oh there it is
she just got a hat uh you get the idea
this is her tweet which says yesterday i
was informed that twitch has
indefinitely suspended advertising on my
channel twitch didn't reach out in any
way whatsoever
i had to initiate the conversation after
noticing without any prior warning
all the ads revenue had disappeared from
my channel analytics
and i'll be honest this is a thing that
i think that twitch deserves a pretty
significant amount of criticism for
is you know even as someone who doesn't
feel like they have a very good
understanding of the twitch ecosystem
it does seem to me like they have a
tremendous amount of inconsistency with
with how they communicate with creators
and i would say that regardless of how
you feel about hot tub streamers in
general which again we will get to
they should be telling the people who
are partnered on their website
before removing their ads they should be
communicating that in any case back to
the article as news.com revealed the
site also
hosts other kind of streams that aren't
necessarily about gaming i love that
news.com.eu credits themselves for that
did you reveal that i don't know that
you did
so obviously for anyone who doesn't know
twitch started as justin tv which was
much more about vlogging than it was
about gaming
and then moved into gaming and then
moved back out of gaming so i would not
say it's a gaming website
i would not say it's even a children's
website which is some of what i've seen
in the discussions here
it is just a live streaming platform
that's it of course it has streams that
aren't about gaming
there's art there's podcasts i do a
mental health podcast every second week
the next episode will be up this
thursday uh amaranth described it as an
alarming precedent
it serves as a stark warning that
although content may not ostensibly
break community guidelines or terms of
service twitch has complete discretion
to target individual channels and
partially or wholly do monetize them for
content
that is deemed not advertiser friendly
something that there is no communicated
guideline for this leaves open-ended
the question of where the line is drawn
many people complain about the terms of
service being unclear but at least has
something to go by
there is no known policy for what
results in a stream of being put on
blacklist
with characteristic opacity the only
thing twitch made clear is that it is
unclear
whether or when my account can be
reinstated
so here are the actual guidelines that
cover nudity pornography and other
sexual content in general
sexually explicit content is
specifically pornography sex acts sexual
services
um completely prohibited sexually
suggestive content they say to maintain
the health of our community and promote
content that is appropriate for a
diverse audience sexually suggestive
content is prohibited on twitch
evaluations on the sexual suggestiveness
of a behavior or activity are
independent of user attire and
and are instead based on the overall
surrounding framing and context
which is complicated because you can be
accused of being sexual
especially as a woman even when that
isn't your intent
just by virtue of having a very feminine
body type that happens to be visible i
have a lot of male friends who stream on
twitch who like
you know the shot is them generally in a
single like bruce green for example
is usually wearing a tank top and the
camera is pretty low on him it's almost
down to
sort of the middle of his stomach i
could wear the exact same thing but as
a significantly breasted woman people
could
take that as being sexual even if my
intent is not sexual at all
even if i'm just sitting there in a tank
top because it's hot
that sexual suggestiveness of a behavior
or activity should be independent of
user attire
because a woman with large breasts just
wearing a tank top can be
considered sexually suggestive when
really it's just how she looks it is
just her
existing maybe it's hot so i appreciate
them for saying that
but it goes on to say content that is
considered to be sexually suggestive
includes but is not limited to
content or camera focus on breast
buttocks or pelvic region
including poses that deliberately
highlight deliberately highlight these
elements
groping or explicit gestures directed
towards breasts buttocks or genitals
fetishizing behavior or activity such as
focusing on body parts for sexual
gratification or erotic role play
i totally do that when streaming
gameplay i do do that
simulated sex acts or sexual stimulation
using or featuring sex toys in context
unrelated to sexual education
interesting erotic dances such as those
involving stripping or flashing
pole dancers or acrobatics with sexually
suggestive framing
posting displaying or sharing erotica
including detailed descriptions of sex
acts or pornography
and it does say here i won't go through
all of this i am reading over it but i
don't want to have to just read it all
to you because there is a fair amount of
text
for those who present as women we ask
that you cover your nipples we do not
permit exposed
underbust cleavage is unrestricted as
long as those coverage requirements are
met which means that having slash
shelling cleavage would not count
as nudity and attire which again i
appreciate okay here we go contextual
exceptions
um swimming in beaches swimwear is
permitted as long as it completely
covers the genitals and those who
present as women must also cover their
nipples
full coverage of buttocks is not
required but camera focused around them
is still subject to our sexually
sexually suggestive content policy
coverage must be fully opaque even when
wet
shearer partially see-through swimwear
or other closing clothing does not
constitute coverage and it is worth
noting that
um a number of creators have been been
banned
streamer i'm jasmine was hit with a
temporary ban
after having a wardrobe malfunction
which is what you see here
indie fox who has 729 thousand followers
has also been banned at least four times
including four rule breaches during hot
tub streams and then sup caitlyn who has
hosted hot tub streams was recently
banned for inappropriate clothing
so people have been banned and yes as it
says the debate around the hot tub
streams is still raging on
this also cites marcus graham which is
head of creator development addressing
the whole hot tub stream
trend directly in a recent live stream
he said our nudity and attire policy
does allow bathing suits in an
appropriate context and hot tubs do fall
under that criteria
that makes sense they account that as
being similar to a beach i guess if you
were just sitting
in your office and playing a video game
then the bikini would not be allowed
because it isn't in the right context
however what has not changed is the
sexually suggestive and explicit content
not allowed under guidelines under the
terms of service and twitch will take
action when that is reported to us
and then they have like a couple of uh
screenshots of angry comments here this
is
nana's felix xqc lengil the most watched
broadcaster on twitch
also weighed into the room this month
calling the trend the most pathetic
thing we've seen on twitch in forever
what a sad reality please get this trash
off the front page she tweeted look at
google giving me ads for the exact
laptop that i'm currently using amazing
so yeah twitch removed the ads from
amaranth's channel
um didn't tell her why but then oh my
god
but then reinstated them after amaran
spoke out about the issue on her stream
and other social media platforms twitch
responded today in a blog post admitting
that its failure to communicate was a
mistake we recently suspended
advertising on some channels that were
flagged by the majority of our
advertiser base and failed to notify
them twitch set
we should have alerted affected
streamers to this change before it
happened it was a mistake
not to do so we're working with
individual creators to address their
specific situations and restore ads
where appropriate
uh amaranth wasn't live on twitch when
the blog post was published
vods on her channel started to have
pre-roll advertisements once again with
the caption start watching
amaranth right after this ad break stick
around to support the channel so they
have been reinstated twitch said that
brands on its website can decide
where and when their ads appear they can
target or avoid specific categories of
content and flag channels that don't
meet their standards
this means twitch and rat cases will
suspend advertising on a channel at the
advertiser's request which is an
interesting conundrum for amazon to be
in or for twitch to be in if your
advertisers don't like the content and
don't want to be seen on bikini content
um
that certainly makes someone's job a
hell of a lot harder so then as part of
all of this happening
twitch actually uh yesterday the day
before
issued this is probably what i'm gonna
use the headline for the video actually
a new blog post saying let's talk about
hot tub streams um obviously this is
part of the ads being removed part of
the very aggressive conversation
surrounding these
so twitch says over the past few weeks
we've seen and had many conversations
about hot tub streams and we want to
address it candidly
the content brings up questions that are
complex with few easy clear answers
so they start off by saying basically
first and foremost no one deserves to be
harassed for the content they choose to
stream how they look
or who they are and we will take action
against anyone who perpetuates this kind
of toxicity on our service secondly
while we have guidelines about sexually
suggestive content being found to be
sexy by others is not against our rules
and twitch will not take enforcement
action against women or anyone on our
service for their perceived
attractiveness
so i do think that this is a very
important thing to point out
finding someone sexy does not mean that
they are trying to do anything sexy
someone having cleavage does not confirm
any intent you can just have cleavage
because it just
exists on your body and i certainly wish
that i could just wear
a singlet we call it a singlet in
australia but i guess most people know
it as a tank top
on a day that's hot without people
treating me as though i'm some kind of
hussy who's trying to get attention
and on days where it is hot like in
summer in la last year when i didn't
have
an air conditioner i had men accuse me
of teasing them
because i'd be wearing a singlet but it
would be cut off at my shoulders the
suggestion
when i was just wearing something
because it was hot was that i was trying
to tease men by making them think that
the camera would slip and that they'd
see my tits
no not how any of this works and it is
so much worse the way that women who
have large breasts are treated regarding
this than women who have small breasts
you could they could be wearing the
exact same thing
one of them is an attention seeking
[ __ ] the other one is a woman on a hot
day
breasts are great why we get mad about
boobs they're wonderful
it's so strange anyway back to the
article
so they go on to say there has been
confusion around whether streams from
hot tubs are permissible under our
content policies
and we understand why our rules as
written have contributed to that
confusion which i definitely
felt under our current nudity and attire
and sexually suggestive content policies
which we've already been over
streamers may appear in swimmer in
contextually appropriate situations at
the beach or in a hot tub for example
which i guess is what's happening right
now and we allow creative expression
like body writing
and body painting provided the streamer
has appropriate coverage as outlined by
our attire
policy which is covered nipples and the
covers can't be see-through
they say our intention with the sexually
suggested policy was to draw a line on
content that is overtly or explicitly
sexually suggestive
not to ban all content that could be
viewed as sexually suggested but we
acknowledge that our rules are not as
clear as they should be to which
i definitely agree they go on to say
that it's complicated sexual
suggestiveness is of a spectrum
there's a degree of personal
interpretation of where the line falls
which is also definitely true
they say they will always aim to avoid
being overly punitive based on
assumptions when we have taken
enforcement action
on this content we've only done so in
the case of clear violation of our
guidelines
to make the lines between what we
consider to be overtly or explicitly
sexually suggested more clear our team
is planning to update our policies on
sexually suggestive content in the
coming months and i
i honestly do think this is probably
pretty difficult to do it is probably
pretty difficult to figure out a way to
phrase this stuff
based on again something that can be
perceived you can perceive someone as
being sexual even when they are not
trying to be
i feel like that is a tough rule set to
write because unless they mandate a rule
that's like everybody must wear t-shirts
at all points in time forever
it is hard to figure out where those
lines are drawn and how different
bodies make those lines be interpreted
in different ways
essentially they also went on to address
the questions from creators about
suspending advertising
on their channels this is once again
about brands deciding where ads should
or should not
appear it says today they can target or
avoid specific categories of content and
flag channels that don't meet their
standards we absolutely do not permit
brands to use protected characteristics
as a filter for advertising targeting or
blocking
we recently suspended advertising on
some channels that were flagged by the
majority of our advertiser base and
failed to notify them our creators rely
on us and we should have alerted
affected streamers to this change before
it happened
etc agreed so my guess
is that um because amazon wants to make
money
because they don't have enough that the
hot tub
tag was added which of course is part of
this they added a hot tub tag
uh because that way advertisers could
choose to opt out of that tag it's not
because they were trying to help hot tub
streamers it's not because they were
trying to help the community it's
because it's better for the advertisers
so that's a breakdown of full events um
and the end to this video is just me
answering the question though i'm sure
you kind of probably already get an idea
of it of alana
don't you think that people streaming
from a hot tub
is hurting female streamers it's hurting
female gamers
my answer to that is no and it feels
like a scapegoat if anything
these hot tub streams have started
popping up more and more in the last
couple of months especially the last
month and as someone who only ever
streams video games i do some just
chatting and some podcast stuff
in a t-shirt with cleavage covered
i've not seen any decline in viewership
for this kind of thing ever i feel like
these are entirely different audiences
who are looking for entirely different
kinds of content
and i don't feel like hot tub streamers
are hurting me in any way whatsoever
because i am not trying to stream from a
hot tub they are so
separate that it is just someone making
a completely different product
i've not had any increase in negative
comments because of that
i don't think that i have people take me
less seriously as a gamer
because of what other women do but even
if they did
i would think that that would probably
come out of them regardless of whether
hot tub streams existed or not i think
that's probably more of an internal
thing that they're conveniently relating
to those women
so i have absolutely no problem with
these things at all it's not hurting
anybody if you don't want to watch you
don't have to watch it if other people
do want to watch it
then they can i know that some more
conservative people
and i mean the word conservative
literally are not referring to that
politically
don't tend to like anything that is seen
as sexual or revealing
but i strongly don't believe that it has
any negative impact on me and
i think you should just own if you don't
like it that you don't like it
but i don't think it's right to pretend
that you not liking it is some grand
protection of other female content
creators because that just doesn't check
out to me
i am cool with people streaming having a
fun time
in their own spaces doing whatever they
want in hot tubs
you have my support and if i don't want
to see it
i want that's it alrighty everyone that
covers all my thoughts on the topic i
hope you guys enjoyed this video again
sorry about the terrible lighting i am
in a hotel room and i will see you guys
next time
bye